I can honestly tell you that this movie
was 90 minutes of the rock taking a
in the woods it would be better than the
legend of Hercules Hercules is directed
by Brett Ratner and stars Dwayne the
rock Johnson in the title role you guys
know the story he faced 12 labors he
defeated lions and boars and armies of
people he's the combined offspring of a
human and Zeus he's really strong and
he's played by the rock who's also
pretty strong in this movie Hercules is
commissioned to help this army take over
this enemy nation and along the way they
got to go through a lot of other people
that this guy is seemingly brainwashing
against them but there's something else
going on under the surface that Hercules
is curious about because he has a really
damaged past with what happened to his
family this is always directed by Brett
Ratner as I said it stars the rock as
Hercules what are you really expecting
out of this one no I got a man I walked
into this movie thinking this is
probably not gonna be the best movie of
the year
Brett Ratner can make a sleek-looking
movie he's not gonna make a terrible
looking film although a lot of his films
lack depth and some of them are truly
awful Dwayne Johnson's awesome I like
him and everything he does but I am
actually surprised to say this movie is
not as bad as I thought it was going to
be is it a great movie no is it a good
movie not really but it's not awful so
there's that Dwayne Johnson is good as
Hercules and when I say that I mean that
he's really big and he's really strong
and he can hit things with clubs really
well he's likable and he's got really
white teeth for a guy from those times
but I guess since he's the offspring of
Zeus he automatically is going to have
fluorescent white lightning white teeth
the movie looks good there are some
impressive battle sequences and the best
part of this movie is that there
actually is a very surprising hook to
the story that I legitimately did not
expect that really did take me off-guard
and then actually improve the film quite
a bit towards the third act of the movie
in regards to depth there's just not
really much happening but it is cool to
see Hercules slicing off heads of
animals and going into battle and you
know kicking people like 20 feet all
that stuff is in the movie and it looks
good Dwayne Johnson is good at doing it
and for that reason I think that the
majority of people who go to see this
movie are gonna get exactly what they
expect that's also the main problem in
the movie - is for the most part except
for one surprising element to the story
I did not expect the movie is pretty
much exactly what you'd expect but I
will say that there was an aspect of the
story that did take me off-guard that I
thought was handled very well the fact
is that interesting twists of the story
didn't happen until there was only like
20 25 minutes left in the movie
everything up until then felt very
by-the-numbers run-of-the-mill and kind
of Aeon worthy at times even though
there really was a couple really cool
battle sequences so Dwayne Johnson is
cool as Hercules he's a cool guy
you know he's a likeable actor Brett
Ratner makes a sleek-looking movie with
zero depth whatsoever an interesting
story hook that happens that really
switches things up doesn't happen soon
enough unfortunately so everything up
until then felt kind of by-the-numbers
I'm gonna give her Kelly's a C+ it is a
little bit better than I thought it was
going to be and it's a lot better than
that other thing that happened in
January so guys I do want to make a
really cool announcement something I'm
extremely excited about something that
I've been looking forward to and
something that I've been working for for
five years I started doing videos in my
room for fun and I hope that one day
someone would look and say that guy's
doing something and he's working hard at
it and he has awesome people who are
watching him let's see what we can do
with this guy I'm being sent to LA for a
press junket in which I'm gonna be
interviewing Sean Bean himself for the
new TNT show legends that's gonna be
happening later in August and I will
post a video of my interview with Sean
Bean I'm gonna ask him awesome questions
if you guys have any questions you think
maybe would be cool to ask him I'd love
to know what you think of course I'm a
huge fan of his work Patriot Games gold
and I Lord of the Rings I mean the guy
is awesome I'm a big fan of his and I'm
excited to be able to do this for you
guys I'm also gonna be going back to LA
in late September in which I'm gonna be
hitting a few podcasts that you guys may
be familiar with guys I'm really excited
about that and I hope that you come
along with me on this ride and enjoy it
as much as I'm going to and thank you so
much for everything you guys have always
done for me because I really owe a lot
to you guys so thank you if you guys
check out Hercules let me know what you
think of it if you don't I mean that's
fine too as always guys thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
[Music]